we bring in the former nfl offensive
lineman
ross tucker football podcast westwood
one nfl analyst
he joins us on the program where do you
want to start
what game what issue what concern
do you want to focus in on first here
ross
oh man dan there's a lot of different
places we can go
but i do the eagles pre-season telecasts
and i do their pre-game
on the official pre-game radio show and
i just got off being on wip in
philadelphia and
they're not taking it real well dan
they're not real keen on ties
in philadelphia i mean look i can tell
you i grew up there now
i seemingly played for every team other
than the eagles but
growing up there i can tell you without
any hesitation
because all my buddies were texting
about it yesterday
they would much rather have tried to win
the game
and lost whether it was trying the
64-yard field goal or going for it
then punt it away they they honestly
would rather
try to win and lose than ty that's just
the mentality i don't know if that's
right or wrong
we'll find out later on the year but
that's how they feel
you have the false start on the field
goal and then that takes you out of
field goal range
and then on fourth down you think eagle
fans wanted them to go for it
knowing you know if they did try to kick
that field goal
the bengals would at least have a little
bit of time and maybe try to win that
game
yeah so it's interesting because in the
moment dan
i guess i kind of felt similarly to doug
peterson
19 seconds fourth and 12
at your own 46 yard line or their 46
yard line
obviously they felt like it was too far
for a field goal
but i remember thinking wow they go for
it and don't get it
bengals have a great chance at a field
goal here
so in the moment i didn't hate doug
peterson's decision
but then i started doing the math
afterwards i'm like okay wait a minute
they're at the bengals 46
if they do some type of sprint out with
wentz he throws the ball down the field
maybe get past interference maybe you
catch it even worst case scenario is
incomplete
there's probably only 11 or 12 seconds
left
and then the bengals have to get a nice
throw to even get in field goal range
and it's interesting because i was on
in philadelphia right after doug
peterson i don't know if you guys saw
this but doug peterson's already said
if he could do it over again he would do
it differently he would have gone for it
and kind of working through the math and
the situation
i agree with him i think going for it
trying to get the first down and get out
of bounds would have been the right move
uh do you like joe burrows future or
carson wentz's future
right now i would say joe burrow i mean
you know you're watching him yesterday
burrow's a rookie with the worst
offensive line in the nfl
honestly one of the worst offensive
lines we've ever seen
i don't love his near-term future
because i doubt he's going to make it
through the season
i mean he got smashed eight sacks he got
hit 18 times
malik jackson almost took his head off
i just don't see how it's unconscionable
to me
how the bengals would take joe burrow
with the number one overall pick
and then put him out there behind this
offensive line
they are dreadful but still dan he looks
like he knows what he's doing
i mean he's accurate he's calm cool and
collected
i don't know what's happened to carson
wentz he's had three years in a row
where he's thrown seven picks for the
whole season
he has six already this year that's
never been an issue for him
he's missing throws he shouldn't look in
his five years
including even his rookie year probably
this is the worst
that wence has played i don't really
have an explanation for i don't know
what anybody does
yeah you start to look at this and i
always wonder you know when i see these
quarterbacks get selected high
and they don't have a good offensive
line i go back to andrew luck you can't
have
a 100 million dollar investment and then
pennies
you know for an offensive line and it
drove andrew luck out
out of the nfl i see what's happening
with desean watson
in uh houston where he takes a ton of
hits there
and that's my big concern with joe
burrow as they move forward
you you know you've got to be able to
bulk up that offensive line if you're
going to protect your investment or then
why are you taking that quarterback
number one overall
russell wilson feels like an overnight
success after 10 years
what is it about russell wilson now
that's different than russell wilson the
last couple of years
yeah well so i've said i've been
consistent with this stand i would say
since about 2014
maybe 2015 i've said that if you could
give me any quarterback for the next 10
years
it would be russell wilson isn't he
waiting isn't he russell wilson jr the
third yeah he's russell's new third now
yeah
so anyway it would be it would be
russell wilson
he is almost perfect in terms of what he
does both
on and off the field the way he carries
himself
the big difference this year is i think
that they know their defense is not very
good
and they can't wait for the fourth
quarter heroics and try to keep the game
close until then
they need to let them go they need to i
mean the strength of the team
is russell wilson and the receivers so
they're just letting them go
and it's unbelievable on on the good
news
14 touchdown pass in his first three
games nfl record he's obviously the mvp
front runner right now the bad news is
dan they're still barely winning these
games
i mean it's really a shame that
russell wilson the offense playing this
well never matched up
when they had that awesome defense if
you could have combined those two you'd
have one of the best teams ever
unfortunately
right when they finally figure out they
need to let wilson go
and let him do his thing the defense is
not very good
what concerns do you have for the
cowboys
well there's a bunch number one their
defense has not played well
at all this year which is a major
problem and then number two
their offensive line has been decimated
by injuries and that's what ended the
game i mean i think dak was going to
have a chance
to give them a chance to tie that game
but you've got
undrafted tackles at both spots i mean
you can't win that way damn you can't
look look i know i give credit to
backups that go in there that was my job
a lot
but they've got guys out there that
should not be playing they had to move
zach martin to right tackle yesterday
because the kid they had out there was
playing that poorly
it's just not a very good recipe for
success so you combine
o-line injuries and o-line issues with a
bad defense
not a winning formula for the cowboys
other than the fact
they're in the nfc east so they're in
first place talking to ross tucker
former nfl offensive lineman the ross
tucker
football podcast and of course he does
westwood 1
nfl analyst in thursday night you have
broncos jets now when i look at the jets
here
i don't know how important this game is
for adam gase i don't know how secure
his job is
i look at dave gettleman the gm of the
new york giants i don't know how secure
his job is
and dan quinn the falcons head coach if
you're going to handicap
how warm the seats are for those
gentlemen
where would you start with the hottest
it's adam gase i mean there are reports
out over the weekend
that they need to see something and then
they went out against the colts
and got embarrassed now they'll be in a
stand-alone
prime time game it's the only game on
everybody will be watching uh at least
some people will be watching i don't
know it's a tough sell dan throw out the
records when the broncos and jets meet
on thursday night football
why don't we throw out the broncos in
the jets
not just listen to me and i an eagle
you're calling the game on the radio but
in all sincerity it is september 28th
then
and i believe we already know that two
head coaches are as good as gone
i mean adam gase and dan quinn they're
done it really is
a matter of when not if at this point
there's nothing i mean adam gase what a
disaster the jets are they're the worst
team in pro football
and for the falcons to blow those
last two games like they did he's not
coming back from that so
i wouldn't be surprised if the ownership
for those two teams already having
meetings this week
to try to figure out when the right time
is to do this because there's almost
no conceivable realistic scenario i can
conjure
where dan quinn or adam gase are able to
turn this around
and we might even have these guys get
let go in the next few weeks and
i would not be shocked if that happens
but i'm watching the jets sam darnold
did not look good at all
through a couple of pick sixes at some
point
the jets are gonna have to if they're
bringing in a new coach
and that coach obviously wouldn't have
drafted sam darnold if they're in a
position to take trevor lawrence or
justin fields
like let's look at this maybe down the
road with the jets if they're going to
be this bad
are they going to be in the market for
one of these two top quarterbacks have
they seen enough of sam darnold to
a give him that extension or they move
on from him
well i definitely don't think they would
give him an extension i mean i think the
jets are poised
to have the number one overall pick in
the draft at this point
and so darnold it's funny because you
said forget about gays
gays is already gays is done gays is
done and
dead in the water thursday night to me
is about darnold i mean
the rest of the season is darnold's
chance to prove
if the jets have the number one overall
pick that they shouldn't
josh rosenham right they shouldn't get
rid of them to get the next guy like the
arizona cardinals did
with kyler murray but at this point the
way darnold's played
and i know they don't have a lot around
him but even talking with
greg cosell on the ross tucker podcast
he said donald's not
playing well i think that there's a very
realistic chance
that if the jets have the number one
overall pick they take trevor lawrence
and darnold gets the same treatment that
josh rosen did in arizona
josh allen's getting some mvp chatter
here
uh how do you assess his game because he
nearly lost that game with the rams he
he built up a big lead but then uh he
got sacked a couple times
fumbled and uh you know they had to hold
on for dear life you all in on josh
allen
well i love him for a couple different
reasons number one
you know the bills of the team i played
the most for so i have an affinity for
him but number two
dan he is probably the most entertaining
quarterback in the nfl
because it's either really good or
really bad
i think he had two personal foul
felonies yesterday
has nfl quarterback ever had two
personal power
before i mean he is must see
tv and we joke about him being a roller
coaster
and the ups and downs but the reality is
this year
there's a lot more ups than there are
downs and that's what you want to see
year one year two year three with every
passing year
there's a lot more ups than there are
downs he's trending in the right
direction
and so are the bills and in a couple
weeks dan october 15th
i'll be there for westwood one they host
the chiefs
so chief's buffalo bills could be an
epic match up
in a couple weeks i think we'll learn
more about the bills then more important
game for the chiefs tonight or the
ravens
i would say the ravens because they are
the home team
they are favored and i think the ravens
are going to win probably by double
digit stan i don't think you'll have
many other people say that
i think the ravens are nasty i don't
think they're just the best team in
football
i think they're the best team in
football by a decent amount you know
they destroyed baker mayfield week one
they were smashing desean watson last
week their defense
is much improved with calais campbell
and then their run game
it's funny i mean i know you know i do
the army games
on tv for cbs sports network going
against lamar jackson
and the ravens running game it's almost
like playing against the service academy
they do so many new and unique things in
the running game
that these these defenses aren't able to
prepare for it
the scout team can't give them a good
look they get out there
they've never seen these blocking
schemes before they don't know where
these guys are coming from
and oh by the way it's jk dobbins and
ingram and lamar jackson running the
football
i really believe the ravens run the ball
down the chief's throat tonight
i think they get after patrick mahomes i
think the ravens have a great chance to
win this game
by double digits great to talk to you as
always ross thanks for joining us
my pleasure thanks for having me that's
ross tucker former nfl offensive lineman
ross tucker football podcast westwood
one nfl analyst what paulie
so we're setting ross up for the zoom
call yeah
and his head's so big we had to ask him
to move the computer back he goes
i'm trying to move it back because he
won't be able to hear me
he has the biggest knock and his head
takes up the whole screen it feels like
one of those bubble cameras
oh huge head yeah good guy
there's that scene in animal house when
uh
flounder's face comes up on the screen
it's just so big and when ross when we
zoom in with ross and then all of a
sudden
he zooms in and you go ah because his
computer is usually a little too close
to him he's uh
he's got uh double duty uh next week
he's got
broncos jets thursday night
abilene christian at army that's on
saturday